New York Times just ran a piece on the  most stylish people in the country and  do you know I made the list  John Federman  John Federman the senator elect from  Pennsylvania the man you know is not a  Gucci model okay the guy was big  oversized hoodies and gym shorts and  he's generally kind of unkempt and he  can wear running shoes and he's not  he's not Marcelo mastriani okay  so why did the New York Times say that  he's an icon of style do you think he's  very stylish no  does the New York Times think he's  stylish no  does John fetterman think that he's  stylish no  that's why they are dead set  I'm telling you that John fetterman is  stylish because they are dead set on  transgressing and subverting everything  that you believe everything that you  know to be true